happy birthday to you happy birthday sir
me Webster
god I love a birthday especially when
the birthday girl is as cute as stormy
that's right Kylie Jenner and Travis
Scott's baby girl is officially one year
old and to celebrate we're gonna take a
look back at her most adorable moments
grab the tissues guys cuz this is gonna
get emotional
stormy proved she was the sweetest thing
on social media right out of the gate
don't believe me her birth announcement
literally broke the internet receiving
the most Instagram likes ever 18 million
and Counting people while that is until
a random egg stole the spotlight oh that
damn egg store me said her first word
and no it wasn't Kylie cosmetics
I'm not crying your cry and I just one
year old stormy is already a little
fashionista in the making whether it's a
Burberry coat or a mini Louis Vuitton
handbag this girl is already rocking
those designer duds and do not even get
me started on all her adorable Mommy and
Me matching outfits from a neon green
swimsuit to a head-to-toe sparkly number
stormy is clearly her famous mama's
greatest accessory and as if that
weren't goals enough stormy is already
going on tour with her rapper dad she
even had her own private room at each
venue and her own hotel room in each
city so me and Travis have our
and I always get a separate room so that
I can put all so I always get a separate
room for my wardrobe my makeup and also
store me so she could play around and
have space since she always travels with
us it's so cute I can hardly stand it
and a source tells ET the cuteness might
just be doubling sometime soon
the source explains that Kylie and
Travis are already thinking about baby
number two quote Kylie and Travis are
going to wait until he's finished his
astral world tour before trying for
another baby they want to have another
child soon so it's close an age to
stormy but they do not want to do this
while he is busy on the road of course
Travis is in Atlanta right now where
he's prepping for the Super Bowl
halftime performance along with Outkast
big boy and maroon 5 et sat down with
Adam Levine who opened up about the
significance of the 26 year old joining
the band on stage he is it right now
he's the one you know it's like this is
a moment for him and we love what he
does
obviously we love what he represents
because we love having there be a
presence that there this is the show
that's gonna have the biggest hip hop
presence that there has ever been on
this on the show I mean I can't look
back and find that to have been the case
before so he's it he's the man right now
and he comes in hot what a year it's
been for Kylie and Travis and of course
itty bitty stormy I cannot wait to see
what they do next I'm personally hoping
for another cutie patootie itty bitty
babe stir and you could count on us to
be the first let you know all the
breaking Kylie and Travis news so be
sure to subscribe to all things et until
next time I'm at Halle underscore
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]